apples 2018 iPad pro is revolutionary in
the iPad world but it also came with a
few drawbacks like the $800 price tag
no headphone jack bengay issues and
worst of all the incredibly powerful a
12 X processor and the new USBC port are
way ahead of what the current iOS
software allows you to do with it but
what if there's an iPad that maybe
wasn't as nice as the pro but solved a
lot of these problems could it be
Apple's brand-new 2019 iPad air let's
find out for starters it comes with a
headphone jack you won't have any
bending issues it's packing the same new
70-meter 812 processor from the iPhone
10 s and it's priced at a whopping 300
dollars cheaper than the pro even better
you don't have to buy a new Apple pencil
if you already have the old one so
that's it right people should obviously
just buy the new air well not quite the
pros got some tricks up its sleeve the
new square edge design makes it look
futuristic and modern compared to the
air but it's not as comfortable to hold
in the hand compared to the old design
the pro gets faced ID instead of touch
ID which works great by the way since
there's no visible knotch
and it works in literally any
orientation even upside down
thanks to face ID there's even bezels
all around with rounded corners on the
display which really makes it stand out
from the crowd and it actually makes it
easier to play games in landscape mode
now the display tech is extremely
similar
there are literally only two differences
the pro is brighter and it gets pro
motion technology testing the brightness
you can see the difference but does it
actually matter much in the real world
honestly not that much now pro motion on
the other hand is huge in my book it
allows the screen to refresh at up to
120 Hertz for buttery smooth navigation
and you can truly feel the difference
now what people don't mention about
promotion is that it automatically
brings down the refresh rate to match
the content you're viewing to help save
battery life so let's say you're
watching a video that's shot at 24
frames per second like this one their
pro will run at 24 Hertz while the air
runs at 60 Hertz wasting battery life
without giving any visible benefit at
all another benefit of promotion is
reduced Apple pen
lack and as you can see in the slow-mo
clip drawing on the pro is almost
instant and it's a difference you can
feel speaking of the pencil the pro
supports the new one which is better in
basically every way especially in the
way it magnetically connects to the side
instantly pairs in wirelessly charges
the matte design feels better in the
hand and it's got a new DoubleTap to
switch tools feature which is incredibly
useful something that's a much bigger
deal than people make it out to be is
that the pro gets four speakers instead
of two on the air it truly makes a world
of a difference you get true stereo
sound in landscape mode which makes a
huge difference for gaming let's listen
to a quick speaker comparison and make
sure to put on some headphones so you
can hear the difference
[Music]
yep the speakers are many times better
on the pro the interesting thing about
the new air is that is the only non Pro
iPad that has a smart connector and
supports the smart Keyboard before we
get into performance let's quickly
mention the camera differences even
though cameras don't really matter much
on iPads the pro gets more megapixels on
the rear for better photos with smart
HDR and 4k video recording at 60 frames
per second
unlike the air it gets quad LED flash
the front-facing camera isn't much
different but thanks to a having face ID
you can take portrait selfies which
really does make a big difference the
pro also packs five microphones instead
of only two on the air so let's compare
them this is a microphone quality test
with a 2019 iPad air this is a
microphone quality test with a 2018 iPad
pro getting into performance that pro
gets the a 12 X chip while the air gets
to a 12 and yes you can play for night
in other titles at 60 frames per second
on both of these iPads in the pro gets 4
gigabytes of RAM compared to 3 on the
air yes you can get 6 gigabytes on the
pro if you buy the one terabyte model
but it's definitely not worth the price
for almost everyone in Geekbench for the
pro is only four and a half percent
faster in single core and a much higher
59 percent faster in multi-core which is
what really matters in the metal
graphics test the pro scored over twice
as high as the air which is going to be
huge for things like gaming rendering an
augmented reality the more realistic and
to to test that takes the processor
graphics RAM and user experience into
account only shows a 47 percent
improvement for the pro for an even more
realistic test we exported the same 4kh
EVC 60 p video file on both ipads in the
pro finished in less than half the time
now that's a significant difference for
video editing so as we can see there's a
pretty big difference in performance but
will you notice that difference in
day-to-day use let's play fortnight
which is one of the most graphically
intensive games on iOS and see if there
are any differences the iPad air runs
the game perfectly at 60 frames per
second on high settings after playing
for a while it's incredibly smooth with
no dropped frames at all I
we couldn't tell the difference between
it and the pro in terms of gain
smoothness and graphics quality the
biggest noticeable difference was only
having two speakers on the air so for
gaming the iPad air can handle basically
any popular game currently available on
iOS so the extra power of the iPad pro
isn't really being used unless you're
one of the few people who is actually
gonna do some things like video editing
and basic navigation and just using the
iPads daily you'll definitely notice a
difference with the pro but it's not due
to performance it's actually due to the
promotion tech you can easily feel the
difference and display smoothness with
the iPad pro and that's what you'll feel
every day the quad speaker setup is also
a difference you'll feel daily maybe
even more so than pro motion so what's
the rundown which ipad is the better
value well the iPad pro is obviously
ahead of its time since the hardware is
all there but it's limited to iOS if
you're planning to keep it for many
years the software will eventually catch
up and you might actually be able to use
all the extra performance some people
will buy the iPad pro just for the new
modern design alone it's definitely a
much better iPad but it's also quite a
bit more expensive now the new iPad air
honestly has enough performance for
almost everyone and the display quality
is outstanding it supports the Apple
pencil the smart keyboard and it has a
headphone jack it's basically the best
all-around iPad currently available if
you're not looking to spend close to a
thousand dollars but it's got a couple
of compromises no promotion and only two
speakers now what if you could spend
that same $500 or even less and get
basically everything the iPad air gets
but with four speakers and pro motion
technology as well that's basically what
you get with the 2017 10.5 inch iPad pro
which is currently on sale on Amazon
brand new for $500 we've got links in
the video description below the a 10 X
chip is not much slower in processor
performance and it's actually almost 50
percent faster in graphics performance
it even supports 60 FPS on fortnight and
runs at just as smooth as on the ipad
air people say that a 10x chip will stop
being supported sooner but the iPad Mini
2 from 2013 still supports iOS 12 so the
2017 iPad pro should still be supported
for at least another 5 years
by the time it loses support you'll
honestly be okay with it since you
enjoyed the much better speakers
promotions technology and better
graphics performance for all of those
years if you enjoyed this video
comparison make sure to hit that
subscribe button because we've got a lot
more video comparisons coming very soon
including videos on the new 2019 iMac
this has been Devine with Mac's tech
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]